n
[Musique]
vous rêvez de vivre loin de la pollution
sur une île quasi déserte de tout lâcher
vous savez bricoler
les îles chausey cherche deux agents
avec logement de fonction pour
travailler sur cet archipel exceptionnel
surnommés les seychelles normande
est le premier qui a décroché ce job de
rêve sur plus de 120 candidatures c'est
lui
stephan faudeux mer
les suites pour l'apéro
les sens
du fait que la boutique est fermée à
aucun commerce et on a un bateau là
aujourd'hui et le prochain bateau est
symbolique donc simon quelque chose il
faudra s'en passer la prochaine vedette
pour chose et dans trois jours ce matin
sur le quai du port de granville c'est
pour ce mécanicien de 42 ans le tout
début d'une nouvelle vie
[Musique]
là bas tous le surnomme momo le nouvel
agent municipal connaît déjà l'archipel
depuis huit ans il y travaille comme
saisonnier l'été mais il passe l'hiver
est une tout autre affaire
[Musique]
stéphane tiendra-t-il loin de la côte où
il est né isolé sur un caillou perdu
dans la manche
[Musique]
après trois quarts d'heure de traverser
voici les premiers rocher de l'archipel
de chausey l'île principale n'est pas
facile d'accès cernés de pièges de
cailloux à fleur d'eau la mort c'est la
seule ou qui habitait en plus de la
grande île il ya une maison en fait de
pêcheurs dessus et puis une petite
cabane à côté après on va aux toilettes
va arriver sur l'île principale
voilà
c'est beau
c'est pas non plus ah oui je pensais
voilà c'est chose et mais on y est bien
on est tranquille et puis tu vois c'est
simple
un rocher de 2 km de long sur 300 mètres
de large la grande île est la seule
habitée toute l'année s'ils sont des
milliers à y débarquer chaque été ils
sont moins d'une dizaine à vivre ici
l'hiver
[Musique]
sa façon
la forme
toi prises le prise de poste aujourd'hui
en fonction voilà les deux fonctions
aujourd'hui
stéphane est accompagné par pascal drieu
responsable technique à la mairie de
granville car chose est un quartier de
la ville ils ont rendez vous dans ce
fort construit sous napoléon iii pour se
défendre des anglais
en poste depuis 11 ans l'ancien agent
eric fromont les y attend pour passer
officiellement son pouvoir
devant ce témoin de granville
personnes et on comprend
bien venu à la qualité de gwen stefani
partie est là maintenant c'est lui qui
va se retrouver à la tête de deux choses
entre nîmes et les problèmes les soucis
tout ça c'est le premier interlocuteur
des administrés de lune
mango
maintenant à toi les
à toi la responsabilité
intronisé nouveau chef de l'île momo
prend les consignes de son patron lille
doit être prêt pour l'arrivée des
touristes dans trois mois ici d'un coup
de karcher partout il faut en fait tout
a beaucoup de personnages
tu penseras faire les gouttières aussi
ouais
[Applaudissements]
les panneaux électoraux ils vont là où
la composent des plots définitif a le
temps de traîner car ici c'est la marée
qui commande le chef ne veut pas rater
le bateau retour au risque d'être bloqué
trois jours sur 7 il ya peut-être board
de monter ça aussi
trois cases pour une polémique smsm et
une pour les autres les personnes
pompiers cooper de roseaux ou encore
livreur d'eau
je pense qu'un grand nulle chacun a une
fonction et que là en face à un peu
toutes les fonctions ici savoir tout
faire
la navette partie lille retrouve son
isolement momo peut enfin s'installer
sympa le logement de fonction il rentre
chez lui parce qu'on le vit
ses meurtrières pour seule fenêtre ça
n'effraie pas mon mot ont vite ici comme
sur un bateau
moi j'ai passé mon vieux bateau à 16 ans
j'ai toujours eu des bateaux mes parents
habitent auprès de la mère ces voix-là
sais c'est pas un changement radical les
gens d'ici c'est les mêmes que chez moi
j'ai ce qu'il faut bon au pire s'il
manque quelque chose s'est vraiment
passé de toute façon est ce qu'on va pas
le voisin et là
est le plus proche cefic thévenin
pêcheur à la retraite
et du vent sur donc là
lors donc les comptes à vue
et comme moi
dont l'une le wild a que ça les a
souvent collé mauvais temps la mairie
dbayé bali l'île balayées par les
éléments et boyer montsalès arrive-t-on
même dans le forez la grosse tempête
habiter ces casemates de la marine est
un privilège réservé aux employés de
mairie aux pêcheurs le patron en gare et
à ceux qui restent l'hiver ou n'est pas
le caractère pour venir travailler à
cholet c'est notre mire fazila venezuela
[Musique]
lille fait la grasse matinée momo lui
est déjà au boulot à bord de son
tracteur poubelle
et
là on va arriver sur la partie privée de
lille qui représente à peu près les deux
tiers de l'île
momo parce qu'ils la frontière la fin du
domaine public pour le village de
blainville ici il y à 45 ans encore vive
est toute une communauté avec son école
sa ferme son église
[Musique]
pas de voiture ni de feux rouges sur
l'île pourtant ce matin le périph est
bondé
en général on se croise pas trop quoi
qu'il a du coup ça bouchonne ce matin on
n'a pas de vélo non plus l'été on se
retrouve avec une population
des fois que 3000 personnes sur une île
qui est tout petit donc
tout le monde est à pied au moins y'a
pas de soucis mais on n'est pas pressé
[Musique]
c'est pas chose et se compare agent
communal je pense que j'aurais continué
dans d'autres métiers on va s'enfermer
sur une île pour avoir de la liberté
donc ça peut paraître bizarre mais en
fait on est plus libre en étant sur
quelque chose en fait quelques tout
petits
jusqu'en avril tout est fermé l'unique
hôtel restaurant et l'épicerie momo va
vivre son premier hiver dans ce petit
monde de granit régulièrement balayée
par les coups de vent rendez vous dans
trois mois
retour est chose est au début du
printemps l'archipel se découvre enfants
ici ont lieu les plus grands marais
d'europe un record qui va nous faire
changer de décor
sur l'eau on a retrouvé mon mot fidèle
au poste plus que jamais pour travailler
il doit jouer avec les marées
des plages où on en parle
carten chansons empreintes
[Musique]
là on va chercher du gaz pour le
chalumeau
en fait on peut pas transporter dans les
navettes à passagers le gaz
en fait je vais donner un collègue
ostréiculteurs
est on va aller la récupérer sur son
bateau pendant la
sur une île il faut souvent faire appel
au système d une soudure urgente
l'attend sinon c'est toute l'île qui
sera privé d'eau
pas le temps de s'attarder pour
contempler ces immensités sauvage il y a
beaucoup pas faire la saison touristique
va commencer
3 8 en
trois mois et demi quoi
journée voit pas passer quoi
momo travail sous la pression de la
marée qui remonte à toute vitesse il a
moins de six heures pour finir de
nettoyer ce ponton qui ne dévoile que
rarement ses petons
appâtés par la promesse du spectacle de
cette grande marée
un premier flot de touristes débarquent
cet équipage la rêve de ce moment depuis
un an
arrêtez c'est beau
ils ont réservé un gîte pour le week-end
les cinq logements communaux sont
plaints aménagé dans l'ancien presbytère
et la petite école
[Musique]
edwige bielle va les accueillir elle a
obtenu le second poste proposé par la
mairie de granville quitté son travail
de préparatrice en pharmacie pour l'
aventure sur cet îlot cerné par les
flots
je suis un peu amoureuse de l'île depuis
des années des années et j'avais
travaillé déjà les dernières en tant que
saisonnière au fil de la ferme au bar
restaurant et puis vient depuis que je
suis toute petite à chose et donc c'est
un petit peu voilà une évidence je me
suis dit changer de changer de rythme de
vie aussi parce que l'on vit un petit
peu de cette liberté d'autonomie et
quand on peut allier l'utile à
l'agréable
on fonce c'est mon petit chemin pourrait
travailler donc ça c'est le paradis
pourtant quand elle a débarqué à choses
et en février pour préparer la saison
c'était toujours du vent toujours
c'était plutôt l'enfer
[Applaudissements]
le plus dur c'est quand les pilotes ont
obligé de couper les moteurs pour passer
les vagues il faut mieux devient bien se
placer dans le bateau si on veut pas
être malade voix
[Musique]
ils viennent chaque année depuis huit
ans
et ne manquerait la marée de cet
après-midi pour rien au monde le
coefficient de 117 est exceptionnel
[Musique]
vous avez une éventuelle questions et de
dire si tout est ok tous partagent le
même espoir que stéphane proust trouver
le trésor de choses est celui qui fait
rêver les plus fins palais
on regarde tous les homards qu'on va
pêcher leur violon sous tous les cas you
lie un homard je vous ai fait des
petites croix pour des homards
il y à chausey version marée haute et
puis chose et version marée basse la mer
va baisser de 14 m peu à peu c'est un
continent qui sort de l'eau
[Musique]
dans cette constellation de 365 kg
autant dit on que deux jours dans
l'année stéphane cherche l'entrée d'une
chambre secrète
très bien s'en sortir à la roma de
taille
là on a encore un peu de temps pour la
pêche je laissais la mer ni porc encore
descendu
je toussais trouver une chambre ou le
homard
s'est réfugié il trouvait un trou
suffisamment profond et il a pu se
cacher
[Applaudissements]
c'est un lieu hors du temps donc quand
on est à choses et en ce sens privilégié
parce que les spectacles et changeant
toutes les heures avec la marée et à
calme elle fait de dormir à choses et ça
vous laisse encore ce petit pire
privilège de te de faire un petit peu
partie de l'âme de choses et
ils ont trois heures avant que la marée
ne remonte le compte à rebours est lancé
à la pisse est on déloge qu'aux frères
coquille palourdes les pêches
miraculeuses pour presque tous
elle n'avait pas la taille des palourdes
le voilà enfin le seigneur de chausey
des petits coups ç'a aidé appelez ça
c'est omar pour l'année prochaine voilà
lui moi ok bon centimètre
pas de homard bleu donc ce soir au menu
vite il faut rentrer pour ne pas se
laisser piéger par le flot
pour regagner le sonde le chenal qui
longe la grande île il faut toute
l'habileté des pilotes
ici on trouve les courants les plus
forts d'europe et ce goulet peu profonds
et plein d'écueils
ça y est la mère a atteint son plus haut
niveau le village a les pieds dans l'eau
et le ponton s'est noyé la vedette ne
peut accoster cale à cale
cette fois le bateau amène un colis peu
ordinaire un privilège accordé à peu de
petites îles françaises
on alors
c'est lui en deux qui va nous permettre
de faire les élections sur josé chose
elle fait partie de la commune en ville
c'est vrai que le trottoir est un peu
large 17 km mais
cet administré par la commune de
granville et ça fonctionne très bien
les bulletins de vote des barques
conseiller municipal de granville en
charge de l'archipel stéphane thévenin a
passé son enfance sur l'île
donc ici c'est notre bureau de vote
voilà c'est chose faite
bon bah merci pour la clé il va
transformer ce poste de secours des
sauveteurs en mer avec l'aide de mômes
au regard des dispositions
réglementaires
tout doit être prêt pour demain matin 8
heures
[Musique]
on est en retard pour l'envoi des
couleurs ces huit heures l'on boit des
coups donnés par le colonel
à 8 heures précises le bureau de vote
peut accueillir les 55 inscrits sur les
listes électorales de chausey
certains comme philippe le pêcheur y ont
voté toute leur vie
[Musique]
d'autres comme clerc sont venus
spécialement par amour de ligne
social important aussi pour maintenir
aussi une une vie locale c'est pas que
une une île avec des résidents
secondaires il ya encore une petite vie
locale qu'on essaye de maintenir c'est
pas évident mais voilà
pierrick lui a traversé la manche pour
voter
tu n'es avec mon voilier qui a amarré
dans le sang voilà pour tels pierrick
peut voter avec ma famille
originaire d'ici quelques générations
déjà et j'ai essayé de vos tâches osé
parce que c'était aussi un moyen de de
garder pied
famille de pêcheurs
peu d'abstention à chausey tous
défendent ce petit bureau contre vents
et marées
après six mois d'hivernage l'épicerie et
le baron réouvert les touristes gouttes
au repos de la marée et demi j'attends
ici le prochain bateau
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impression d'être au bout du
monde ici en fait
penser que vous allez rester ah oui oui
ah oui moi c'était vraiment une
opportunité
mûrement réfléchie et
après voilà j'étais aussi dans le
commerce parce que faut aimer les gens
faut aimer
leur faire plaisir parce que c'est
vraiment allier l'utile à l'agréable
pour l'instant à mi temps sous contrat
d'un an renouvelable est vie j'espère
vivre ici d'autres hiver
momo lui est déjà reparti pour embarquer
les matériaux qui serviront à réparer le
sémaphore
plus que répondre à une annonce tous
deux ont changé de vie pour rejoindre le
clan des irréductibles de l'archipel de
chausey